bap bap bap getting a lot of questions
about advice for couples that are in
quarantine together honestly I don't
have any I just send you all my love and
like because I cannot even imagine I
mean my friends are telling me that they
are at the point where they are fighting
so much that they're fighting about
fighting you know when you're like
halfway through a fight and then you
start fighting about the way the other
person fights you're like oh really
you're gonna do that thing where you
exhale super loud during a fight you're
just gonna say you with your lungs
to me your respiratory system is
completely ganging up on me right now
no you're doing that thing were you in a
fight your sternum is calling me a
and then you start fighting about the
way the other person fights and you like
forget what the fight even is you're
like what were you fighting about what
was the note before I started getting
pissed off about the exhaling what were
we fighting about why were you exhaling
in the first place and then to try to
remember where you were fighting about
you just like start listing everything
you hate about the other person you
start listing all the person's flaws
you're like we're we're fighting about
was it was about how you shave your arms
and leave the hair in the sink no what
was it Oh was it about how you always
have like 12 Instagram dm's but you only
have like 5 friends and that math
doesn't add up at all was that huh-uh
oh my god was it about how you always
leave your plate in the sink for
me to clean up like because you think
you live in like a hotel or some was it
that oh wait was it wait a minute it
could have been about how you do put
your plate in the dishwasher but when
you do it always has food on it
which means I have to take it out and
rinse it or else if I left the food on
it it would get in the machine and break
it you dick nose was it that huh
are we fighting about was it about how
you always send the emoji with the heart
eyes to your ex when she sends you
photos of her baby which is obviously
insane no was it about how you follow
browsers on Instagram No
was it about how you always accuse me of
forgetting things which I don't hmm
trying to remember what I hated about
you today uh you know what just if you
just keep being yourself just keep
walking around and like talking to me
and stuff and I'm sure remember I'm sure
that you just existed will jog my memory
I don't remember the thing that I
despise you for so just yeah just be
yourself we'll circle back to this huh